you mentioned medellin by the way how do
you pronounce the medellin
both are fine i think the
there they'd say medellin because that's
kind of the accent is the on the double
l but that's but medellin is would be
totally fine as well what lessons do you
draw from the medellin cartel from the
different gang wars in colombia medellin
uh what's the
economics of peace and war between dark
drug cartels here's what was really
insightful for me so i live in chicago
and the chicago people are aware that
there's a violent problem in chicago
it's actually not the worst american
city by any stretch of the imagination
for shootings but it's pretty bad
um and
medellin has these better much many more
and probably many better organized gangs
than
uh chicago
uh and yet the homicide rate is maybe
half
um
and
uh now i mean there have been moments
when these gangs go to war in the last
30 years when medellin has become the
most violent place on the planet but for
the most part right now they're peaceful
and so what's going on there
um
i mean one thing that is there's a hair
there's a hierarchy of organizations
so that above these reasonably well
organized neighborhood gangs there's a
set of sort of more shadowy
organizations that
have different names some people call
them resonates some people would call
them bandus corinales criminal bands you
might just call them mafias
and they there's about 17 of them
depending on how you want to count
and they themselves
have a little operating board
called sometimes they call it the office
la fiscena sometimes they call it
um la mesa the table well each
individual one or as a group as a group
as a group so they meet and they don't
meet personally all the time sometimes
they mean but they consult
a lot of the leaders of these groups are
actually in prison and so and they're in
the same wings and prisons they have
represented oh they meet in prison well
they're whatever if if i'm on a cell
block with you i'm beating you anyways
right so actually imprisoning leaders
and putting them in the same cell block
but not putting them in you know if you
get arrested here in the united states
and your criminal leader and you get put
in a super max prison you cannot run
your criminal empire it's just too
difficult it's impossible there it's
possible and you might think and they do
they still run their empire and you
might think that's a bad idea
but actually
cutting off the head of a criminal
organization leading it to a bunch
leaving it to a bunch of like hot-headed
young guys who are disorganized is not
always the path to peace so
having these guys all in the same prison
patios
is actually
it
it it reduces imperfect information and
uncertainty right it provides a place
for them to bargain they can talk and
and so lau facing is like a lot of these
informal meetings and so so you know and
and they have these tools that they use
to control the street gangs so instead
of there being like 400 gangs all sort
of in this anarchic situation of
competing for territory and constantly
at war the resonates are keeping them in
line
um and they will use sanctions
they will
where they'll sanction might be i will
put a bullet in your head if you
right if you don't a little more honest
there's no more sanctions between
nations exactly but they will but they
they will sit them down they'll they'll
provide they'll help them negotiate they
will provide commitment i said there are
these things called commitment problems
where like there's some dynamic i have
some incentive to like exterminate you
but that's going to be costly for
everybody so i'm going to have what's
the solution well i'm going to provide
commitment i'm going gonna like enforce
this deal
and yeah you don't like this deal now
because you could take advantage of your
situation
and wage war but i'm gonna give you a
counter incentive and and and so they
keep the peace and so
and it's a little bit so they're a
little bit like the u.n security council
and peacekeeping forces and sanctions
regimes it's like the same kinds of
tools the same parallels
and and they're imperfect they don't
always work that well and they're
unequal right because it's not like
they're pursuing this in the interests
of like democratic blah blah blah
um
but it kind of works
until it doesn't and and 10 years ago in
you know the mid-1990s there were wars
and this breaks down and i it kind of
gave me this perspective on the
international institutions and all the
tools we've built that we do the same
things right sanctions
are designed to
uh
make unchecked leaders face the cost of
war
it's a solution to one of the five
problems
right and
mediators are a solution to uncertainty
and international institutions that can
enforce the peace and agreement are a
solution to commitment problems and all
of these things can be solutions to
these intangible incentives like these
preferences for whatever you value and
mis calculations because they will
punish you for your miscalculation or
they will get a mediator to help you
realize why you're miscalculating so so
they're doing all these things and it
made me realize that the comparison to
the on security council in our all our
tools is actually a pretty good one
because those are pretty unequal too
and those are pretty imperfect
like that's you know it's there's these
we have five nations with a veto on the
security council and
a lot of unequal power and they're
manipulating this in their own
self-interest or their group's interests
um
so so anyway so it's actually the some
of the
things that work in medellin and why
they work help give me a lot of
perspective on what works in the
international arena and why we have some
of the problems we have is like so
there's not
in some deep way there's not a
fundamental difference between those 17
mafia groups
[Laughter]
i'm sure there were different they have
different cultural garbs that they wear
yeah uh what are your thoughts i mean
that's the sense they got from pablo
escobar and jorge ochoa who founded the
car the medellin cartel
is
like uh having spoken with people on his
podcast talked to roger reeves who was a
drug transporter it seems like they're
it seems like it was
um i don't know the right
term but it was very kind of
professional and calm
it didn't have a sense of danger to it
like it's negotiating so like the danger
is always on the table as a threat
that's part of the calculation but
you're using that threat in order to
de-escalate in order to fps everybody is
interested in peace
so something that happened last year we
were a little bit able to watch in real
time because we had a few contacts we've
been meeting and talking to a lot of
these leaders in prison and a bit
outside of prison
many of them will talk to us um
and so
uh they're
the homicide i mentioned homicide rate
and medellin's
maybe a two-thirds or half of the
chicago level it had been climbing
some of these street-level gangs
were starting to fight
um
maybe at sort of the on some level it it
seems that like maybe some of those
horizon leaders were like saying well
you know we're actually not sure how
strong these guys are let's let them
fight just to test it out let's have
these skirmishes right it wasn't
prolonged warfare it was like let's just
sort of feel out how strong everybody is
because then we'll be able to
reapportion the drug corners and stuff
accordingly
so they're kind of feeling each other
out through fighting
and the homicide rate some doubled and
then it and then it increased by the
same amount again and so is approaching
something that might get out of control
which wasn't in anybody's interest was
in the government's interest wasn't in
their interest and so then magically
um
all these leaders in these patios right
different prisons are they're spread out
around a bunch of prisons everybody gets
transferred to a new prison on the same
day
which means they all get to be in the
same holding area for three days before
they're all moved elsewhere so the
government had a role in this
and then somebody who's like a trusted
mediator on the criminal side gets
himself arrested
happens to be put in the same spot
and uh
and a week later the homicide rate has
is thirty percent of what it was
uh it's back to its normal mode
unfortunately not zero right but it's
back to where it was
uh because they
it didn't make sense to have a war and
everybody government
mafia leaders everybody sort of like
they figured it a way to sort of bargain
their way to peace
you